[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video i'm going to be
discussing the boy who lived
harry potter as well as the fabled elder
wand
more specifically i'm going to be
discussing the actions that harry took
at the end of the last book film after
voldemort had been defeated
and where harry was left as the true
owner of the wand
the first thing worth mentioning is that
the fate of the elder wand varied from
book to film
in the book after repairing his own wand
harry lays the elder want to rest with
dumbledore
the following excerpt conveys harry's
words to dumbledore's portrait in the
headmaster's office
i'm putting the elder wand he told
dumbledore who was watching him with
enormous affection and admiration
back where it came from it can stay
there if i die a natural death like
ignotus
its power will be broken won't it the
previous master will never have been
defeated
that'll be the end of it in the film
however a very different course of
action is taken
in the film the fate of the wand is far
more drastic
as harry dramatically snaps it in half
it's mine
what should we do with it we i'm just
saying that's the elder wand
the most powerful wand in the world with
that we'd be invincible
harry pauses and has second thoughts
then snaps the other wand in half
destroying its power before tossing the
two halves into the abyss
ron and hermione proudly smile at harry
so they're different
however one thing is consistent from
book to film harry being worried about
the power of the wand
the elder wand is undeniably the most
powerful wand in the harry potter
universe
it was the first hallow created made by
death himself
and no other wand is its equal
possession of the one
also meant that you could produce magic
which was not otherwise possible
and to say that the one would be
dangerous in the wrong hands is a
massive understatement
let me clarify something in order for
the elder wand to truly change hands
the current holder must be bested by
another witch or wizard
that is disarmed or defeated bearing
this in mind
book harry left the wand in dumbledore's
tomb so that the wand would naturally
lose its power
his thought process was this if the want
is detached from the world
and the one is never taken forcibly from
him then no one else can be its true
master
his understanding was that if he died
without ever losing possession of the
wand
then it could never change allegiance
again rendering it useless
and most importantly unable to be used
for evil
this is supported by the following
excerpt from the book the previous
master will never have been defeated
that'll be the end of it film harry on
the other hand had a different approach
he didn't want to leave things up to
chance he wanted to be sure
the one could never be used for evil
again and what's the best way to do that
snap the wand i think it's safe to say
that the film method was safer
however there were also a few holes in
book harry's logic as long as harry was
still alive
the risk of him being disarmed killed
always existed
and whether he was actively wielding the
wand or not the person who bested him
may become the elder one's true owner so
in this respect
harry's logic was flawed does that mean
he made a mistake
was the elder wand just waiting to be
taken in actuality
the elder wand was safe just not for the
reasons that harry thought
harry's initial view was i want to be
defeated therefore no one will become
the new master
but this was not realistic particularly
as harry pursued a career
in the aura department however the life
of risk and danger that harry would
eventually follow
and the high likelihood that he would be
disarmed at one point or another
is actually what kept the elder wand
safe the fact that he would likely be
disarmed by countless other people
throughout his career
who would unknowingly become masters of
the other one and that they themselves
would likely be disarmed by countless
other people
means that the path of the one's
ownership will become too convoluted to
follow
in this regard harry's plan was in fact
accidentally
effective so no harry didn't necessarily
make a mistake
but he certainly didn't think it through
entirely
do you guys have anything else to say on
the matter what would you have done with
the elder wand
personally i think i would have kept it
for myself until next time
every human life is worth the same and
worth saving
who said that comment down below